e
[Aplausos]
em 2019 eu tava na casa de um amigo meu
enquanto ele se arrumava para o encontro
Ele me disse que estava atrasado e que
precisava passar na farmácia antes de
chegar no bar eu pensei que legal um
cara prevenida que se cuida vai comprar
camisinha não ele ia comprar Viagra
E aí você deve estar pensando Nossa esse
teu amigo devia ter uns setenta e poucos
anos não ele tinha 23 anos na época o
homem saudável tem disfunção alguma
bonito engraçado mas inseguro
é inseguro com medo de falhar
é inseguro com medo do julgamento dos
outros e seguro com medo de passar
vergonha
Oi e o quê que é a vergonha
E a vergonha o sentimento que nós temos
o medo de perder vínculos E a vergonha
faz a gente se sentir que nós somos
defeituosos e portanto em dignos de amor
e de aceitação
e o meu amigo nunca tinha falado daquilo
com ninguém ele me agradeceu pela
conversa ter sido tão tranquila sem
cobrança sem julgamento e melhor de uma
forma leve
E por que que ele nunca tinha conversado
daquilo com ninguém tabu
e hoje eu quero conversar com você sobre
os maiores tabus dos homens e vamos
falar algo que ninguém nunca fala mas de
modo simples e direto o que que é um
tabu Tabu é algo que é proibido e que
não se discute seja por questões Morais
e religiosas ou por pura hipocrisia a
gente sabe que quando tem um tabu na
mesa todo mundo se levanta é o maior
Tabu para mim de todos os tempos Eu
costumo chamar de Tabu dos cabos EA o
que ninguém discute mesmo ninguém Coloca
a mão
e hoje com 38 anos de idade eu posso
garantir para vocês que o maior cabo do
homem é pensar que sabe o que é ser
homem
e o que que é ser o meu pergunto a vocês
pense o que é ser homem
é a primeira resposta automática que
alguém poderia dar é muito simples Tiago
indivíduos que nascem com vagina são
homens ou mulheres indivíduos que
nasceram com pênis são homens Tá certo
tá errado
com esse raciocínio não simplesmente
removemos todas as pessoas transgênero
da sociedade
e eu um homem se gênero nasce com pênis
tem um mas os homens trans não E aí Tá
mas então é fácil a mulher engravida e o
homem não não
e as mulheres transam podem engravidar
rapidamente elas não tem outra mais os
homens trans tem eles podem
Oi tá Tiago então o homem é o que gosta
de mulher você tá errando muito
e os homens gays possuem relações
afetivas sexuais com outros homens e não
deixam de ser homens
Oi e aí tá minha última chance ago
Existem algumas características que são
exclusivas dos homens virilidade
pensamento lógico liderança coragem para
amigo você já viu Amanda Nunes lutando
FC eu não tenho coragem ela tem
focado corajosa determinada todas as
características que serão facilmente
relacionados a um homem
e os homens podem não ser nada disso
aqui e ainda assim ser indecisos
delicados e motivos o que que define uma
pessoa ser homem
e a gente pensa tudo isso que eu falei
porque nós estamos imersos num conceito
chamado de menbox ou traduzindo a caixa
do homem a caixa do homem é um conceito
de Imaginário como se lá dentro dessa
caixa existissem regras nós temos que
seguir para sermos homens de verdade a
caixa dos homens nos diz que para sermos
homens o indivíduo tem que ser homem ele
tem que ser hetero forte e corajoso com
prontidão sexual ativos sexualmente não
demonstrar sentimentos nunca nunca
chorar ser corajoso
dominante em relação a mulher está no
controle Não falhar nunca Olha eu
olhando assim eu tenho certeza que eu
sou uns trinta por cento homem né E é
difícil é complexo mas eu tenho a
resposta para vocês o fato é que para
você ser homem basta você se sente homem
e sim entender esse ver como homem
e a Judith butler já nos dizia aqui
gênero são construções sociais
gêneros são performances são
comportamentos aprendidos a gente
simplesmente aprendeu a um menininho
gosta de azul e a menina gosta de rosa
porque
o porquê
E quem disse isso para gente
e tem uma definição fechada do que é ser
homem para mim é um dos maiores tabus
porque simplesmente ninguém fala disso é
como se fosse proibido no Brasil para
grande na maioria das pessoas
Infelizmente essa conversa que a gente
tá tendo aqui agora nem deveria começar
mas simplesmente não pode ser assim
é uma pesquisa inédita que saindo 2020
baseada em dados do Sistema Único de
Saúde o SUS mostrou para a gente que a
cada hora uma pessoa LGBT que ia mais é
agredida no Brasil
a segunda Acra Associação Nacional de
transexuais travestis o Brasil é o país
que mais mata pessoas trans do mundo
46 por cento das pessoas mortas desse
grupo eram pessoas trans
e Obviamente as idades variam conforme a
classe social e Raça Mas a questão é por
quê que isso acontece porque
porque as pessoas simplesmente não
aceitam que esses homens sejam homens
e as pessoas decidiram escolheram não
pensar sobre isso homens gays transe
morrem todos os dias por que as pessoas
escolherão eu não vou falar sobre isso
a tensão sobre isso Alguém já pensou
aqui o que é ser homem o que que é ser
homem o que que é ser humano quais os
desafios que a gente tem daqui para
frente para tentar viver numa sociedade
um pouquinho mais justa eu tenho começo
de resposta não precisa desesperar
E que tal se a gente começar a entender
que o Homem também chora
engole esse choro ou você vai virar uma
mulherzinha que homem que nunca
escutou isso de um tio de um avô de um
pai só que essa frase possui três graves
problemas o primeiro deles é misoginia
porque nós vinculamos o choro a fraqueza
e as mulheres como se elas estivessem
num patamar abaixo do nosso
e em segundo lugar vem a homofobia
Porque se o chora nós homens de
verdade não podemos nem passar perto
desse universo e em terceiro lugar mas
não menos importantes quando a gente
proíbe meninos e homens de chorar nós
estamos obrigando esses indivíduos esses
seres a reprimir em seus sentimentos
como se sentir emoções fosse algo errado
e a gente tivesse Segurar a Barra tudo
sozinho O problema é que essa ideia de
que para a gente ser homem tem que ser
forte não pode demonstrar sentimento a
gente não pode falhar tá matando a gente
e há um tempo atrás um tio meu muito
próximo falou assim Thiago terapia é
coisa de gente fraca homem fraco e eu
Tiago vindo aqui eu pensei eu tive uma
porrada de coisas que eu só passei
fazendo muita terapia como é que uma
fala de uma pessoa tão próxima hein
poderia a Ressoar na minha cabeça se eu
não tivesse bem resolvido nessa questão
vocês entendem é óbvio que a depressão
atinge homens e mulheres estão na
verdade mas segundo o Ministério da
Saúde os homens se suicidaram quatro
vezes mais que as mulheres e para trinta
por cento dos homens depressão é coisa
de homem fraco igual com meu tio e
porque tudo isso porque a gente não
discutir isso a gente não fala
abertamente sobre essas coisas
E nós homens somos podadas desde a
infância é a repressão de sentimentos
junto com a repressão de sonhos eu tinha
um sonho quando era pequeno de ser tem
uma dupla sertaneja famosa
claramente não é dar certo eu não tenho
o cabelo para fazer um bom Penteado
e eu não tinha problema com esse sonho
porque esse é um sonho possível para um
garoto mas os meus amigos que sonhavam
em fazer balé teatro Dança
E eu perguntei para os meus seguidores
Vamos tentar burro Quais são os deles
foram barrados por cabos um deles me
respondeu abraços Thiago eu amava dançar
mas os comentários a minha família me
fizeram parar fechado
e o outro respondeu quando meu pai
descobriu que eu fazer ginástica
olímpica invés de futebol ele cancelou
Clube imediatamente
muitas pessoas e famílias vinham e ainda
vem uma distinção muito nítida de coisas
de homem e coisas de mulher mas isso
simplesmente não existe
E aí quando a gente chegar na
adolescência ou
E aí cai aí a 0 do pé do frango
Eu imagino a cena real eu tinha 16 anos
eu tô no churrasco junto dos meus amigos
ainda terminar pelo menos um churrasco
eu me vejo entrando no banheiro com uma
régua na mão aqui Maravilha
É eu sei que você já entenderem sim eu
tava indo medir o nosso estandarte de
ouro era o assunto do momento quase uma
disputa quem é o mais homem por aqui e
como que a gente resolveu decidir isso
medindo a única coisa que representaria
um homem de verdade a gente não fazia
ideia que aquilo dos fios era tudo
mentira
os corpos de reais uma performance
inatingível e o egoísmo em relação ao
prazer alheio uma mentira que contadas
muitas vezes vira verdade na cabeça e
muito adolescente e tudo isso vai
descobrir com meus trinta e poucos anos
que tamanho não é documento
e o meu amigo que eu contei no começo da
história também cresceu na deseducação
eo tabu ele cresceu acreditando em
performance e começou tomar remédio sem
nenhuma necessidade eu vou falar um
negócio para vocês aqui também ouvindo
homem tudo bem se a gente falha na hora
H
é de verdade eu já falei meu pai já
falhou meus amigos já falharam eu tenho
certeza que várias daqui também vocês
estão duro olhando pensando será que ele
sabe que eu já falei eu sei
o segundo uma matéria que saiu no portal
UOL cinquenta por cento dos homens com
mais de 40 anos podem ter algum problema
relacionado
já entre os jovens a principal causa é
psicogênica ou seja nenhum fator físico
explicaria dificuldades e por que tantos
jovens assim como o meu amigo falham e
busca por soluções perigosas
ansiedade e medo de falhar
bom e porque tudo isso porque a gente
não conversa abertamente
Ninguém tem a conversa que a gente teve
aquele dia um tabu
em todas essas histórias que eu tô
contando só essa com sociedade nos
contos e tem uma outra muito famosa que
é história do homem provedor se já deve
ter escutado sobre isso bom provedor é o
homem que provê que fornece que abastece
em casa né E aí vocês estão pensando
muita gente sim uai mas não é assim não
esse aí não é o papel do homem não quem
foi que disse que essa papel do homem e
em uma história real o homem está
afundado na vergonha por estar
desempregado
ele diz abraços é engraçado o meu pai
sabe mas a minha esposa não há seis
meses eu acordo todos os dias e vou sair
de casa como se eu fosse para o trabalho
pego o meu carro atravessa a cidade
inteira sento no banco de uma praça e
procuro emprego lá
e em 2016 no Rio de Janeiro o homem
matou os dois filhos à sua esposa e
depois cometeu suicídio
a justificativa é a falta de recursos
para o sustento da família
na carta que a polícia encontrou tava
escrito lá nós não teremos mais renda eu
não vou conseguir mais sustentar minha
família EA pergunta que eu faço é Quem
que falou isso para ele
nossa falando isso ele
Oi irmã matéria que saiu em fevereiro
2020 do Jornal Estado de Minas mostravam
crescimento no número de Lares
brasileiros sustentados por mulheres em
1995 eram 25 porcento em 2018 esse
número subiu para 45 porcento quase
Metade dos lares brasileiros sendo
sustentado por mulheres e a gente aqui
discutindo o homem provedor não foi
nesse sentido a minha mãe foi provedora
em casa durante muito tempo e meu pai
não foi virou ler nos homem por isso
entendi A grande questão é quem diz isso
para a gente porque
esse homem que briga pelo título de
provedor é o mesmo homem que jamais vai
se permitir experimentar novas formas de
prazer
e o Tabu é tão tá bom que eu resolvi o
salário de maneira lúdica e brincar com
vocês
homem tem pavor de pensar em se deliciar
com a sua própria rosquinha
a entender um dos maiores tabus
masculinos e que está social a
exploração do próprio corpo na busca
pelo prazer esbarra mais uma vez a
homofobia porque você levantar a mão
aqui agora e falou assim a minha
namorada adoram se deliciar com a minha
rosquinha Sou Eu que peço pronto
e não que ser gay fosse um problema
Jamais seria Mas não é verdade
eu simplesmente não ligo mais porque as
pessoas estão pensando
perto de acordei e pensei o corpo é meu
dedo também Pingo você feliz
e quantas coisas você já deixaram de
fazer simplesmente com medo do
julgamento Quantas coisas vocês deixaram
experimentar com isso esse tão pensando
Tiago pelo amor de Deus me dá uma
resposta o segredo onde tá
você bem crescer o segredo tá dentro de
cada um de nós
em cada atitude Nossa em cada
comportamento em cada esquina nas ruas
nas escolas em casa no trabalho
a violência que você não viu o abuso que
você não notou a intolerância que você
não sentiu Você não viu no motor não
sentiu mas a responsabilidade é sua é
Nossa o conselho que você dá para um
amigo
e a fala que você tem um churrasco da
firma ou silêncio que você cala no
almoço de família
e o medo do julgamento
e em frente às incertezas da exposição e
o risco seja vulnerável
É eu sei que discutir tabus é um grande
desafio pessoal eu sei muito bem disso e
Sim coloca a gente numa posição super
frágil mas Nada supera a leveza de você
ser quem você realmente é um ser humano
os tabus foram construídos por nós e
cabe a nós destruídos
e eu realmente espero que essa fala
tenha feito algum sentido na cabeça de
vocês e que vocês consigam pensar um
pouco mais e quando alguém perguntar
para vocês o que é ser homem vocês
consigo abrir o sorriso no rosto e
responder ser homem e ser humano
Obrigado senhores
E aí